Magdalena chaud d'ovnik mcdalena bonjour
quel est l'enjeu de cette rencontre on
sait que les deux chefs d'État sont
censés s'exprimer à l'issue d'une
conférence de presse cet après-midi
oui bonjour tout le monde c'est c'est
déjà connu que depuis début des
invasions de l'Ukraine pelle à Russie la
Pologne est en partenaire important de
l'Ukraine donc on attendait cette visite
le président azalez déjà rencontré le
président Douda quand vous avez déjà dit
et ils vont discuter des discuter des
questions les plus importantes
concernant la sécurité mais aussi
l'assistance au réfugiés ukrainien
résidant en Pologne et c'est ce qui est
ce qui est le prix le plus important
mais ils vont parler aussi de la
coopération entre la Pologne et
l'Ukraine dont le domaine par exemple de
formation des médecins craignant en
Pologne mais aussi des solutions
commerciales qui faciliteront le travail
des Ukrainiens en Pologne mais aussi en
retour des entreprises polonais on
Ukraine il est possible que les
entreprises polonaises soient impliquées
dans la reconstruction de l'Ukraine
après la fin de la guerre
merci beaucoup Magdalen